ladies and gentlemen it's Wednesday it's
a hot Wednesday it's a hot Wednesday um
would we author I I'm so glad you got
into that I need to hear everything I've
been very curious she around
I say have AIDS in the stomach you know
I always joke around yeah and she goes
we should get you checked for HIV though
what oh [ __ ] okay she does it's a small
small chance of what goddamn I started
laughing oh come on
it's definitely not that yeah let's not
waste all my time Channel four eight -
you didn't determine do you want to do
you want to check for Ebola like what do
you want to show you what a waste what
did the gastroenterologist yeah you know
the doctors are doctors I now man it's
almost a waste of time well well because
she goes really until we run your blood
there's not much we can do oh yeah oh
okay yeah well price you just did that
first instead of wasting my time now
they'll do they'll don't run your blood
they did a bunch of tests EKGs ulcers
she does Walt a that's not all sir it's
done also it's not know she was feeling
I don't know yeah it would hurt and you
wouldn't be able to eat oh dude I had an
ulcer in yeah and then she said is there
is there uh you know blood and your
throw-up anything like that no no that
yeah why didn't you throw yeah that
should that be it and also some other
things right yeah this is like a well I
love how I love how serious they get
lost either doctor she goes weren't
getting any cuz she goes what's probably
go I have AIDS in my stomach
no one laughs no one last no I'm at all
okay um we should get you checked out
for HIV I'm like okay waste of [ __ ]
time and then she goes vote oh she was
just she was going through all the stuff
she goes it's not an ulcer it's not this
we can cancel that out
could be a virus nope been on
antibiotics o2 killed it you know nobody
called bacteria yeah in your stomach
which is what we went over all day yeah
no a virus a virus no no no not a
bacteria yeah it also would be a virus
oh no yeah a bacteria yeah so it's a so
they went through all that and she said
that she was have you changed your diary
said to her about the ketogenic diet
she's like nice
fasting in the coffee she was definitely
stopped the coffee and then she did say
something interesting she goes do you
use marijuana oh yeah I do I do
frequently man why are you trying to
smoke especially when you sleep right I
said when I sleep I use a spray I don't
you smoke I use a spray ah it's the CBD
with cinnamon and she goes stop doing
that
oh it really she goes I'm not saying
that's the culprit but just out of all
the things you listed coffee and stop
doing that she was into it your blood
work back
Wow I know what did she say about CBD
like they don't know but it can cause
she said in very very small cases CBD
the marijuana can cause some stomach
issues for people huh also I don't know
how knowledgeable they are on Mare well
well they see a lot of people right so
like I wonder also if sometimes they put
things in the CBD oil that you don't
know about you know so makes you wonder
ya know yeah she said the marijuana
could be triggered something in my
stomach
yeah especially because you're it's an
empty stomach and all that that doesn't
make did you tell her that your energy
was low on the tub and then she has
diabetes run your family said yep my my
dad has it my uncle has it my grandma oh
really
yeah she's like well we should take you
for that they checked my blood sugar
levels I was fine yeah I got tested in
college for diabetes I was always tired
off asleep from training get all the
goddamn time and trying to get education
but they ran tests they found I had low
testosterone hmm which would be a
function a lot of times I like of your
training that much your testosterone
below yeah but to have that in college a
little weird have you had
did she test you for every they did
everything there they did a whole blood
panel derby when do you get it back
about a week no she said two days
probably mmm does they do it right there
in house okay you see a little
nerve-racking in it
not really yeah I was like oh very cool
thanks for nothing so I was in Sweden
with my family and I just well the night
before I'd gone out and drank a shitload
of wine and ate a bunch of cheese and I
was you know that dude in his New York
City in that stinky cheese like it got
get that cheese from that
weel that's been sitting there and do me
a favor and cut that out and then mash
it on a board on a wooden board first
clean the best now I'll have the bread
and make sure you put your fingers all
over that too please thank you add the
wine that's 15 years old thank you so
much with this elite it's go a little
mold and that wine if you don't mind now
this is in [ __ ] New York Oh in the
building that Dov Davidoff you stone
this place called in attacker closed
down one of my favorite places what
Sweden have to do with it so the next
day I go to Sweden with my family and
dude my stomach starts to hurt and a
long story short I can't eat a goddamn
thing because my stomach is in pain nah
24/7 nerves are payments
I got sharp stomachache I got a
stomachache like just okay yeah and then
I did I then it kind of go excited some
yoga I do some yoga to get my energy my
my stomach shoulders moving rules man
the stomach chakra moving yeah exactly
and then I would and I do these round or
circle yeah yeah then I eat then I did I
get hungry and they had these really
good food I eat and then and be terrible
terrible then I try to drink beer my
mother you know you know your mother has
some there's bro science and there's mom
science let's hold school old school try
some beer when I drink beer huh anyway
no throwing up just bad pain like as in
no [ __ ] either like no so uh I go to the
doctor and it was so funny I mean I I
can't get to the doctor fast enough I
can't but I'm oh I'm sorry did I mention
I'm on I'm in the fjords of Sweden some
of those beautiful parts of the world
I'm in the summertime the few words I'm
in the archives cover that down there
uh I can't member it didn't matter I was
I would pay that would have paid on his
own dollars all for your he'll stop for
help especially when it's okay just get
rid of one hundred if so if you give me
10 G's all your anyway [ __ ] yeah hold
from the but account [ __ ] get out of
here [ __ ] yes I've got broken hopeless
price ah you don't realize it until
you're [ __ ]
health and sex open bomb I got thank you
and and so I'm I'm just my stomach so I
go through a week's I'm on an island I'm
on an island and it's beautiful but I
can't do a thing yeah there you go
the Stockholm fjords I'm out there oh
it's beautiful it's beautiful now is it
just whites or it's it's it's sumo sumo
LeBlanc that's French for it's just
whites should my look so beautiful
that looks like a scene it does Lord of
the Ring it's incredible and by the way
that water couldn't be cleaner you can
use a warm swim in the water in
Stockholm right in this city yeah
Stockholm is an incredibly beautiful
city this means do it right they do it
right Oh Mike oh yeah it's a bitter cold
there not in the summer and summer it's
amazing oh and by the wall stays light
stays light until about 12 or 1 o'clock
in the morning food to the best some of
the best food we gonna move we got to go
there no let us move there because it
stays it stays dark it stays light in
the summer time for real until 12:00 or
1:00 so it's a party all the time and in
just all whites white bike and whites
good-looking Viking whites with much
longer femur bones than me you'd be
ready if you don't think someone's
dropping in bombs around that
neighborhood you know there the Swedes
are notorious for being the most
unprejudiced people that discriminate it
because the surround by whites well no
they there they're the most liberal
country of course yeah they just look
like they also allow everybody in so a
one-eighth of their population is
immigrants many from Syria and they're
having problems - how - serious problem
they have a major crime serum that they
let in major rape crime he wants to say
it but it's [ __ ] true so is Germany
yeah it's true and these are a lot of
young men who've just never been the
first of all they've been to a war for
five years and they've just it's a
disaster but anyway no roots in the
community but it was so [ __ ] amazing
I couldn't get to a doctor fast enough I
run to a doctor in London this top
doctor that we think it will doctor
looks me and he goes well I highly
suspect that you have an ulcer and I go
I hope I guys um I'm now know I'm like
clearly is no it's I would put probably
all my money on the fact that you
haven't also and so I'm going to I'm it
we'll run some tests and see if you have
the h pylori bacteria in your which is
what it was gave me some antibiotics
done gone [ __ ] gone and and
thank God dude I fed thank god I've had
so many people show up that all the I've
had so many people dear
me and email scary [ __ ] scary [ __ ] but
also what they did to get rid of what
they took what happened to them I mean
somebody got some serious summer and
then somebody like I did this doctors
need to tell you this Dutch didn't do
this so I talked to a gastroenterologist
who said sometimes people come in and
they just have stomach pain and not an
ulcer and they don't know what to do and
and it should be quiet area could be
they I think he thinks that it's a it's
a lg Miss sort of a imbalance in your
gut biome yeah an imbalance in your
bacteria and wheat that's a new science
I thought that the doctors she goes
could just be going through a phase
where you in bounce you thinking all
this coffee I think she goes how's your
work done what non-stop yeah you don't
sleep a lot you work your ass off you
also work out and you fast mmm and then
I'll see you some days you'll drink 16
cups of coffee correct I've had coffee
and uh what I do like about you is it
you don't you you actually are the
farthest thing from a hypochondriac no
you don't give a [ __ ] I just feel like
it's gonna go away and how about me I'm
always like I think I'm gonna die I have
a thing on my life if this if you had
what I heard you like Brendan I'm
actually flying to Vancouver tomorrow
I'm seeing us the tops stomach specials
in the world okay think you just have
gas such a [ __ ] yeah I just like to
ride it out it's gonna catch up with me
one these days I don't think some guy
it's it's cool though man
the fan base some guy reached out and
was like dude you're a dad now I get it
you've been after your life getting an
entertainer your dad now if it is some
serious you can get checked out yeah and
I was like god damn he's right yeah I
love that people are like that cuz I had
a fan when I was talking about my feet
being wouldn't when I wake up in the
morning yeah he goes I don't want to
scare you but you could have cirrhotic
psoriatic arthritis and you got to get
that checked out because it's not almost
area I was like what the [ __ ] my feet
haven't heard since I've been waking up
dude I got a happy feel scary I got
happy fall check someone be like Oh bro
you have Crohn's you have what Brock
loves in her head you can meet surgery
relax all you got it I'm like what the
[ __ ] no no I don't think you have
Crohn's and I I don't know but I don't
think nothing it's a phase
right yeah yeah I'll be all right it was
so funny yesterday man I met with that
was that yes yes yesterday I met with
that stylist for efore the girl I met
with him to have a pic of the know I'll
have him sent me and so you can get
Superman you hit so bad already man I
can't wait to post the fake just for you
I think of you Ben when he came in it
was so funny too frantic he comes in
he's like this top right designer
stylist shoutout to Warren
he comes in tall handsome jump tall six
five in shape from London knows this
fashion like a [ __ ]
I come in there's just all this stuff
laid out and I'm looking and cuz you
have to eat nicely grandma's got a dress
pretty nice we don't have to wear all
black now like the Golden Globes so you
can get you can peacock a little bit
sure he knows my style yeah he goes he
goes I just want you to look around just
look around tell me what sticks out to
you and I go right to this coat I should
go tania's I knew you're gonna pick that
that's the one I was thinking oh it
really goes I don't know what you have
me I have no idea why you even have me
here I went right this is the one is yes
no try this on I put on use I came and
we catch you right now I went really
here's a Caitlyn with you right now
somebody goes I can't even okay yeah
here's all these shoes he has off his
shoes I'm wearing no sock loafers with a
tuxedo pant right
he's tailoring the pants and you know
what he goes with shoes and I go god i
think these egos this is the exact
outfit I picked up I went dude we're too
good together
oh we're to God and then go to high five
oh boy
can I ask you this it was on accident
though you know when you're supposed to
go like that when you miss you for your
sister and I went I went like this
alright now do you think that that your
girl will be willing to share tiger like
on the weekends or how is that going to
come game when you move
who's still funny though that's so fast
and then I then I beeline from there I'm
in escrow on the house and the guy
running the inspection goes bro I listen
to the show big guy like big tough guy
yeah listen to the show
you know I know Collins looking for a
fight and I'd be honored to take that
fight looking for a fight I'm there to
run through the chimney and doors W
looking for a fight and well sounds
leaking for one I'm not he goes I'm your
guy went no not out yeah I don't know
he's gonna make tough guy tough dude
yeah I'm not gonna and I know nothing
about him let's put on some headgear and
really bang it out what stuff dude
absolutely not dr. bright boxed his
whole life like I'll get crushed like
Stone Cold Steve Austin he'd be honest
I'm not fighting you everybody out there
me and [ __ ] are gonna spar he's just
messing her house what da [ __ ] he goes
full thing a week training camp we'll
film it we'll do it the whole Emily ah
dude I check out that leak over there I
I said to Wayne McCullough I go I want
to practice my defense so throw punches
at me and I didn't have headgear on and
put on my mouthpiece just cuz we're
gonna move and I want to practice my my
cross guard gonna do that over what the
[ __ ] man he's he's just he and he fought
it 119 and what what's frustrates me as
I go I go just all [ __ ] aside I go
you know I've been doing this a long
time now now would you could you knock
me out could you actually finish me in
the first round you're just messin
around though I know but it just drives
me crazy
if you went to square it last 20 seconds
crazy yeah not Jim let's [ __ ] if you
like turn your back and ran yeah you'd
last me 30 yeah because he takes your
body their body goes watching everything
goes over your head like it he's over
here they tell you what he was gonna do
an IQ that's right anybody go I would
just throw a left hook Brian and I can't
anything it's [ __ ] nuts is it though
no that's like him trying to stand up
yeah I yeah I just feel like I've been
doing it for a while now and I know but
just cuz you do some doesn't mean
doesn't mean I'm gonna
world champ that's true i skateboard on
the weekends yeah I can challenge Tony
Hawk - no you're not no you're not
no it's just not commit especially with
boxing because they see first of all
they see everything you're gonna do
because you're a [ __ ] beginner but
with everything yeah it's not just
boxing would go play basketball the guy
plays bad roll with it was like when I
watched your your Henner roll while he
was on the bottom and I was like what I
was like how the [ __ ] but he's been
doing it that long they're experts
they're acts but they can get it's naive
for anyone to think that because they do
it part-time they can well it's like
when you that's the brother it's the
same people that sit on the couch and
watch football go I could make a better
throw that okay okay it's just people
get this delusional sense that you know
because they're rounded because they
watch it they know what they're doing or
they're on equal levels yes the round
yes that's exactly right
you know those people those minions that
hang around you know Julia those minions
that hang around Juliet that look like
[ __ ] like they look like low levels at
the Lea but he hangs around all of them
and Julia's killing it and then they
think they're like him you know and then
the good you know today that's probably
not the best example because those guys
are actually I'm just nicely funny no
but I I know you mean like I have the
better the example is like I remember
one time were you it's like when
somebody wanted to join you and the top
jujitsu guys in a practice oh yeah and
they were a civilian mm-hmm and it's
like and it wasn't them but somebody
else had said he should go down and roll
with you guys and it's like well hold on
here no no no because there's there's a
huge difference in levels like you can't
just those also our job though it's a
role you're not coming in to roll with
lyoto machida and Brendan Schaub and
Hannah Grayson Gracie run no no no
that's not that's not how it works
they'll just be so fun in Saturday
mornings but that that's no different
than someone going I'm the funny guy at
the barbecue I'm just gonna jump in with
a cat's and I live that Saturday is that
cool yeah that you would never do that
yeah that's insane exactly that's insane
exactly yeah it's it's that's kind of
one of the things I love about life it's
one of things I love it
like the guy played squash it was Jimmy
Jimmy played squash with a guy who was a
national champion a squash at squash you
hate money well yeah he played in
college but he was a national champion
and Jimmy was playing a lot and Jimmy
fancies himself an athlete because he
plays lots of stuff and he's been
playing ball so long that he'll find a
way to beat a regular guy like me no
matter what right so the guy goes so
Jimmy was so they were playing and
having fun and Jimmy goes let's play a
game and he goes yeah you know now let's
not play game let's just work on our
strokes and Jimmy this come on I love to
play a game and because how do you think
I'll do and the guy gets said to him he
goes hey all seriousness he goes I mean
to be honest with you I don't think
you'd get a point and he goes in a game
and he goes no intention 10 games
because you wouldn't get old I don't
think you would get a point off me if we
played you know as long as you want so
Jimmy goes yeah Jimmy's like Bo come on
yeah you can't do that to him you can't
do silly they played 5 games he got a
point you got eight one boy you got a
point
still I know he couldn't little win go
play about good plays real ping-pong and
see I see so you get about bad if you
play basketball or in a rec league and
you're a grown man and you play let's
say three times a week on a full court
basketball and you play one-on-one
against any starting NBA player in the
world and you will not score a single
point not a singer if there it's dead
serious you will not even get a shot off
yeah I love that [ __ ]
it's real let's show pros vs. Joe's yeah
sometimes the Joe's would be them you'd
finally play like Division three
football's like a running back you'd
like shake Herschel Walker some yeah
yeah and the guys not really expecting
it it's hilarious but like happened that
show tennis is interesting because I
placed so much and I try to play and
then I played with some d1 players they
were xt-1 plays a man dude so Joe you
were hitting the ball so hard though yes
bouncing over my [ __ ] head will
remember it's like people who play golf
like you know most guys play dull I've
done I thought that Max Baer has been
around a real pro yes I have I been on
the tour at Tebow's thing Bubba Watson
was there uh I mean I mean in his sleep
his these guys
that's always like a mile that's cool
where do you want it you want just a
half an inch to that you're a scratch
cause it's what you threw their experts
man the experts they're experts it's a
whole different thing pros vs. shadows
gotta remember when Arturo Gatti knocked
the dude out remember that I don't
remember a lot of it I kind of get
there's a great one where Arturo Gatti
and this guy this big guy is is fighting
it's fighting Gaudi and they decided to
start boxing and Arturo just dips dips
and then just comes over the top and got
some Alex and the [ __ ] out right good
for him though yeah Amir bully beatdown
with Jason main same thing
Arlovski would beat the [ __ ] out of
people in that LSU beats I sewed rampage
I know hilarious
well that's like a dove moved around
with Gotti and got hit him in the body
what God do you um oh yeah they bring it
back to some [ __ ] no do you remember
when when my orga was smoking at boxing
burner when he was around and he won
spar with me yeah he wanted to spar with
anybody yeah and they go hey give me a
couple rounds on it no God no what's
wrong with you I saw the shot
why did you smoke a cigarette some
cigarettes and he will with a guy like
you he'd tee off yeah you'd have to take
him down to beat nightmare oh my god um
last night I watched that movie this is
a sleeper and it's so good our boy
Feldman told me to watch it
yeah it's called winDriver dude I'm just
about to say this I saw yesterday the
flash yesterday I was about to say I saw
it was about to over I was about to go
win River and then he asked what a
[ __ ] movie runner what a movie movie
dude so intense
okay so they directed that Taylor
Sheridan was on Sons of Anarchy as the
cop had a little party was a sapling
actor and he's brilliant we got to get
him on the pot that movie is oh good and
the girl in it check it out you know she
is I know she is she's the Olsen twins
younger sister phasing in it she's so
good at nothing easy on the eyes easy on
the eyes and such a talent jeremy renner
maybe my favorite actor how cool
just [ __ ] love them you know he's got
an IQ of like 175 isn't Howard Stern
goes things must come easy I have a
friend who has an IQ that high and
things come easy is that the case with
you and there was a pause and he goes
yeah yeah he uh he fixes houses you know
and like he'd you know he's like a guy's
day like why can't we balance with I
want to be friends me true man I said I
go I want to get him on the podcast I
want to be friends with her I know
people like Grillo knows Grenier oh yeah
we should get Heldman knows him yeah of
course he's awesome that movie was so
good heartbreaking was so good
heartbreaking
I just come on if you're gonna watch it
I'm gonna mention some it's not spoiler
alert but see any of a hint so zone out
in three two one
at the end the way the way gets revenge
is exactly
hundred percent yes and and the writing
was so like it's like yep here to cold
us no it's so Dean you're out the movie
is d it's deep [ __ ] and it's so real
it's intense and then they go they go
what are you doing he goes and he looks
at the guys cuz they're looking for the
killers and he goes I'm a hunter what
you think I'm doing
yeah like dad I'm so good damn the quiet
badass she goes the other she does
how well do you know the the mountain
around here goes like it's my job it was
like it's my job and he goes because it
is because it is I forgot about that
part
and now the contrary I love that how
hard is know how hot is is ex-wife
pretty Pocahontas now dude that Indian
time I know who is she I bet you should
never say no she's an Indian angel but
she's Mexican I bet you so Spanish
hundred percent ah maybe or did they
cast every Indian and Hardy I don't
think that's her is that her sure no but
that's like oh that's a girl her movie
isn't as Bo she's beautiful too Julia
Jones there's only a few yeah yeah Julia
Jones is not Indian no she's from Boston
yeah
all that I love oh yeah she's looking at
me through the cancer do you need to it
was like no I saw her she nobody she
spoke to me I'm not no I'm trying to be
you just come with the bonus DVD extras
and then they're like what's your
inspiration why'd he do it she goes I'm
just doing the skipper in is it a no no
no Brian see say so a lot people thing
was Brennan and should Brian Brian run
so she was Brian runs tension so you you
read and I understand why you'd say
Brennan well Brennan I felt in a good
way well her hair as if her hair is
different yeah yeah job she liked it she
looks like it like she's out of comic
book a strong jaw that's a body to I'm a
fan
oh look go back [ __ ] is that who's that
with the door boy hey I like Josh yeah
buddy Josh Radnor yeah how I Met Your
Mother
I like Josh I had a main guy in How I
Met Your Mother I don't watch that huh
josh is into singers so she might be a
singer too no no Josh is no no he's with
my girl my body I still don't know who
that is Josh he was on sitcom How I Met
Your Honour notices ask oh he's a real
intellectual sort of hippie guy I don't
have to get we're gonna have to get him
on a squat rack we know that we're gonna
have some money well she's into that she
ain't gonna be in the big brown well I'm
the exact I I happen to feel that Laura
the ass and a fat dick in front when
when when big brown walks by with some
Tsongas with some song goes well night
and I threw it three in them I think
it's hard for a woman not to she gets
the hungry eyes not as she's into that
well that that's until she sees what
she's missing you think yeah because I
love Josh I love him too he goes by he's
a Prius and she's like I love Priestess
yeah I go by my about 64 [ __ ] yeah no
you're a nanny with a blonde ass and fat
curd lights in the front it's a lot of
work takes a lot of gas okay
it's not tamable you got to take a class
to learn even a door dry to blow your
hair back it's gonna blow your
can hear back me exhaust huh it's it
makes noise mm-hmm yes but you safe you
say so that the time when you're in the
car yeah he's gonna be a wild ride
well those things you know it's a little
bit like this too these things you know
but you gotta fill it up hey you better
fill it up you want a pet oh this golden
retriever over there if you want Korky
standard Corgi or you want a wolf you
want a wolf
I got to keep him in a sanctuary we'll
bring it out under my supervision you
can give them a couple pets yeah but I'm
out to tell you where to don't pet his
head don't look him in the eye watch it
watch watch your P's and Q's you guys
don't know she's a wolf
I know suddenly you can get your
standard core you're going retriever
those are the fun look harmless at beach
you take it let me take you Oh yourself
a hyena hyena I'm one of those Heinie's
with the big mask on yeah you've seen
that in India walked in the streets that
thing's fun you take that mask off and
I'm stripping everyone's dead they're
hermaphrodites - I think they also got a
dick Anna and a puss oh that's why let's
not say groups they go they're huge oh
now you won't be a lone wolf ah I'll be
off then let's disregard diet you know
well I didn't know the line is crazy and
a crazy us they got them them tucked in
backsides look bring up bring up these
you know i20 asses rip that we've
already looked at the the Heineman of of
nigeria but bring up the old spotted
hyena why their ass is inverted like
that they just think I'm a big man now
maybe they kill each other as pub bait
they've got this fratricide room where
they kill each other there's a fox
though the cutest [ __ ] but they also you
know they have the hardest
bite of on track hippo crack hippo bones
and and they like to eat rotten meat so
there they got some bacteria going oh
how about I'm watching the show you stay
on PLC late at night can't sleep
watching TLC huh it was shown just a
horrible story little boy in Africa
playing with his friends he's smallest
one hyena goes oh look at the small weak
one damn it attack this boy ripped his
jaw and face on them the little boy that
they they he had reconstructive surgeons
actually
storing the African doctors were able to
help on but ripped his face off yeah
that's horrifying
well back there you know though there's
a woman told story um wrote a story that
I read she was she was from Long Island
just a regular girl decided she wanted
to rebuild a rehabilitated I anus and
the hyena turned on her one day and grab
is surprised because she was in its cage
that African I you know as I say I don't
attend the thing looked her in the eye
and bit a piece of her thigh off and
swallowed it home I went I'll take a
piece of this cuz I can crack through
hippo bones you have a Long Island you
have a Long Island dancers thigh
probably with some shoot she was she was
an ample woman ok so there's some meat
on the whole she's a thick e they're
they're they're very like you know what
there was much meat on yeah she was she
to her own to wait her own description
she was a bigger than normal and a
bigger than usual young lady and the dog
yeah the hyena went well that looks
delicious
you look delicious as a lot of men find
that that delicious yeah but they don't
want to either
you right and then he went on and then
bit and swallowed a piece or a thigh and
then I think to went back for second
what world are we living where people
think it's cool to have a pet hyena do I
want wood yeah oh why because a woman in
Thailand the woman in Thailand dude who
another college girl who'd just dad
probably studied history or something
and comes to Thailand and said I want to
stay here and work and by the way she
says it's fine to be in the tiger cage
as long as you don't fall down you just
can't fall down oh that could be me
that's a big that's me with that's me
older with a tan with a that's me older
with a ten-speed you mean that's my
future yes to have stomach problems I'm
still throwing up so I've gotten waist
kidding huh my head's obviously grown
cuz I'll meet you gotta char money in
your dog no that's a thing going
megaphone yeah still just to yell up the
[ __ ] thing that's we can't just talk
stammering my in a place look at the Sun
I you know I he's going back keep that's
a gargoyle look at that dude
you kidding me right now with those
hyenas they're so cool look at that kid
riding like that power these guys don't
[ __ ] around dude yeah I'm gonna leave
the mask on them you got it dude
no I'll look at the Sinead O'Connor what
is that about
that's her just embracing I you know
Brian I guess so dude keep pictures Oh
oh my god that's a kid on his ie 'no i
guess like dogs they they will end up
being that's amazing and I feel like
it's a bad idea
hyenas look so rugged they look of
rugged hey look there's that story about
the Hells Angels who had a pet hyena
they had to they had two wild boars and
a pet hyena late' yep in their basement
and when they took a championship
fighting dog pitbull and they pitted him
against each other and hippo couldn't
wait to get to the hind it couldn't wait
scratching look at that and well
apparently the pit bull attacked and the
hyena stood and then bit down on the pit
bulls skull kill me kill rushed his head
what were they thinking mediately
mediate oh my god they're like what it's
a gnat to them
yeah they well don't people have really
strong jaws not compared ie it was like
why why excuse me
holy there's a wild dogs now those are
wild dogs that's how I'm gonna fight in
wild dogs
wild dogs God well those are excellent
because they they are but he's not still
bro he's not happening but they'll get
in the booth they'll get in a group and
just start hamstringing you hyenas are
such a badass animal yeah yeah ah that
thing's so close to your throat sir that
thing and you have those big earrings
then I gotta practice some weird show
that oh you know I think they look they
look evil they do don't they they look
like they are just gonna turn the gates
of hell yeah they do they look like
they're Sarah [ __ ] they're also
considered cowardly
their behavior in the wild is rather
cowardly they they hang in groups the
gang up they'll gang up on a female lion
yeah obviously not the male we all know
there's nail comes they go check please
we all know that the male lion ain't
here in a [ __ ]
well it is [ __ ] that's some [ __ ] you
know what give us if you know we gotta
entertain I could see doing some
[ __ ] like this you know what it
gives me it does make me a little jungle
if your spin-off doesn't work out that's
you in five years I want to be where's
bran I want to [ __ ] a Bryan in the
[ __ ] Africa I wanna be that making out
with I eanes dead bro hey hey real quick
on the watch man slice my spent if you
can watch my spin-off ABC tonight at
eight o'clock they're actually looking
to see what kind of social media
feedback I get all it so it could be
reacting look at me this thing oh yeah
if you guys everyone please Rogan
everyone's well really yeah thanks man
that's that's but if it doesn't work out
look at you and that was me that's
making out with ie knows phase 3 crisis
yeah we all did awesome
I gotta I gotta clear work again what a
good guy thank you dude
that is that is that is a big animal
that's a hundred and seventy pound
animal you know they can get it be about
that you need them you can't hit a hyena
you would never eat a haina because they
eat dead meat so that's why it's like
eating a vulture
eating up well it's like yeah if you
tried to eat a hyena first of all you
would have to chew for a long time began
to be very very hard there's a lion
right there it'd be very hard to do that
and also if you didn't cook it really
really well you'd get trichinosis of
weird [ __ ] yeah no I'm not
hey you can never eat an animal that
eats other and other animal flesh eat
crabs you and you know that's different
than you different see in the season is
different yeah but you don't want to eat
an animal like a bear in certain times
you'll get trichinosis they all have
trichinosis
yeah radiata okay why the alligator
though you know what trichinosis is do
you know cuz my friends in your in your
mouth yeah they stay there for seven yes
but you can eat crocodile - crocodile
tail they eat dead you mean it looks you
can eat krokodil a you can eat the
krokodil a but I think crocodiles for
the most part actually eat
living animals but I think you also have
to cook crocodile but you have to cook
crocodile well you're saying wrong now
you have to cook the [ __ ] after you
catch everything they're rare no you
know no rare bear everybody no rare bear
okay beer it up yeah and in the Old
Testament in the Jewish Bible they tell
you there's in the Book of Leviticus
there are long instructions for what not
to eat feel like what are they doing
don't eat an osprey you so that's a bird
that's a bird of prey no birds of prey
don't need eagles hawks or Ospreys why
well because they eat other animals and
they eat dead animals they prey on the
loser the dead animals right now the
live animals but they all eat they're
opportunistic so I'll eat whatever so
what happens is if you eat an osprey and
you don't cook it properly whatever
first of all it's very tough meat second
of all you'll you can get really sick
with different pathogens so who the [ __ ]
is eaten he also they do any of demons
you didn't mean big because you know the
Muslims and the and the Jews don't look
Jews in them in the Quran and the Torah
don't eat pig yzg eat [ __ ] they eat all
kinds of they agree with that
trichinosis I agree with that man so I
like this [ __ ] make ass yeah pigs nasty
yes now Oh chin expel both gotta piggies
did I ever tell you we were in [ __ ]
China in the mainland and this is 1983
82 in China in the mainland communist
China and we go to a restaurant and
there are a bunch of pigs underneath the
restaurant live big we can hear them in
and I look through and it smells I'm
like what the hell and my mother goes
get away from there I know why she goes
that my friend is the latrine and as you
poo in that restaurant
those pigs eat it up so the pigs were
living on the patrons poopoo I'm a story
very sad it smell like pure [ __ ] in
there well no because the pigs lop it up
immediately they they if you lop it up
is lopped or is it glob it up I don't
know but either way it's long but they
can't wait to lop it up when you poo a
pig is going to eat it pigs will eat
your head they'll eat your foot and
they'll eat your [ __ ] and by the way if
I put you in a pig pen after a while
it's all gone
no no those expensive sneakers are left
yeah yeah maybe yeah well that's what
the mop you got to do a crocodile will
eat your [ __ ] sneakers and they can
digest a nail their [ __ ] acid in
their stomach is strong enough to digest
a nail a nail so is coca-cola so they're
gonna laugh you know true but they're
gonna laugh at your sneakers those
sneakers are the coating around the
candy see I like a nice pig though not
to eat I like him as pets
yeah pig I saw a lady walk in a straight
up pig now I like pot-bellied pig
straight up farm pig down Santa Monica
pulled over stopped see can I touch your
page heels sure first of all that's you
sir
crunchy as [ __ ] I think you told me
about that super crunchy grab his nose
grabbed everything they're so strong
yeah if they feel like it like a little
sighs nothing
yeah that thing is so much stronger than
you and and smart
yeah the smaller happens if you get an
evil Pig you gotta make him evil you
know they're not born evil ooh I like
the hairy ones have you ever just [ __ ]
you y'all lotion that thing up man if
you're gonna have a pit not those the
[ __ ] cute now regular Pink's cute
like that yeah I'm tawny man you got
lotion them up you need a nice like you
know that that lotion my dad puts on his
heel because if cracked heel yeah yeah
that's what they mean you would on their
nose you would rub your pig down every
day like it was where's Brandon he's
rubbing his pig down again I'll be all
right dad he'll be out these rubbings
Brandon stop rubbing the pig down we got
it with dinner's ready
look at them I'm almost done look at
them and why is your dick out damn it
he's rubbing his dick I can't prove and
it is anyone have sex with pigs like
they do sheep yes yes pigs have vaginas
apparently that are similar to the human
you making that out I might be but if
you think we still don't [ __ ] pigs
you're out of your mind the problem with
the pig is that they'll turn on you you
know she put you guys lead it toward
water and it backs up and then you can
[ __ ] it and it's not doing much you got
you can grab on to its thing where are
you gonna grab a pig we'll run away with
you're so big have you seen that that
video of a dude who jumped on the pig
get the video on it's on one of these
websites the [ __ ] pig you jump on a
pig that thing will take off on you a
grown man
well no man take sunken took off so you
can't [ __ ] a pig because you gotta keep
it out you can put it in a crate and
then [ __ ] it now all right bro hey there
ya guy riding our Pig any of these I ran
the pig gun wrong that's so funny that's
so [ __ ] funny you've seen where these
Eagles grab goats right and throw them
off the mountain have you seen that it's
it's so [ __ ] up it's so cruel what the
[ __ ] is wrong with these goddamn devil
so mean all right I'm hanging out get
him off get him up he's on me he's I'm
helping I'm helping look that one
opening I know you got to just hunker
down and sit still dude don't ya don't
do this that's tough the Eagle is the
Eagles like I'm fine I'm fine
ouch oh [ __ ] oh I think this guy won
this one I don't know about that that
Eagles fine holy [ __ ] that's he he was
going for a run
[ __ ] a eagle suspect awesome ah nope
nope Danny goes riding that's a [ __ ] I
can't shake your that's working heart
valve me hey bro I need a ride or die
seat like that one in the back no the
stet ride or die sheep is like I'm
trying out what am i doing Larry just
stop the only one they got a Lowen that
look how [ __ ] up the EULA's wow that
ego that ego was [ __ ] aggressive but
what Oh bro hey man now let go now thank
you for flying eagle your way enjoy your
flight down life at ease
hey watch how far they let them go look
at thank you for flying American
Airlines it's we don't land anywhere Oh
how's it going buddy hey bye it was
sunny day out huh where you going you're
going for a ride
oh yeah they call me death from the sky
from the sky hide hide hide death from
the sky death from the sky
that's a big wolf - oh here comes
they're not they're not making noise
hell no you're just like oh he's really
gonna grab this little puppy wolf death
from the sky silent death from the sky
I'll get to get to him get to a puppy's
like that so quickly it's an interesting
looking burn house go little fellow
quickly oh boy oh no oh here comes the
mom hey mom little happy oh [ __ ]
Oh No hey mom gonna hurt pep in your
step
nice one bums me out no hold on it's
nature gets its nature oh it's just like
nature but that's a farmer because he
just took oh man please don't mistake
it's [ __ ] up by this bird and is that
just your standard parrot yeah no I said
that's a cockatoo that's my Australian
cockatoo oh my she sees something
oh oh oh [ __ ] that's a hawk trying to
get at her trying to get that costume
the cockatoo Dan that's a crazy [ __ ] Oh
Bob that's good though she knows her
Birds what the [ __ ] is that a guy oh my
god that's it
broseph let's kill this hopper me dude
I'll punch that bird right in this
[ __ ] beak you see that thing trying
to kill that guy this is good hey what
is this the best visit Lauren birds are
super territorial and oh yeah they're
gonna dive bomb you this sucks
oh my god what the [ __ ] is he doing
zipline no he's hang gliding oh it's
stuck in this thing
Oh [ __ ] stupid bird come on it's just
stuck in there well that's a problem you
know what can I say this on record I
hate birds yeah man
birds are not seeing them - like that
little wolf they're dinosaurs I had a
bird who has him I had no but I had a
giant macaw man see look at this he
crashed I had a giant car and they
[ __ ] what my girl Jezebel would try
to bite women she'd bite through your
shoe she bite right through your shirt
have those Peaks I've made of stone oh
and then what are those birds the guy
goes don't let him out I go I go
they'll take know this they'll take a
table apart they'll take your finger
apart clear yeah I had one or I grew up
my aunt sue and my uncle skip had one
his name was Jacob he's one of those
great parrots with the red tail he's all
great with god that's a that's a frickin
gray smartest person asking we'd walk in
go like you'd have to say hello and keep
saying it yeah that muhfucka remember
everything so my my give me a cracker
man he'll give me a cracker my aunt had
one and her husband came home so my her
husband came home car drove up he got
out
door closed put his key into the you
know put this key in door open
said it hey hon um it was the bird the
bird mimicked the sound of the car
perfectly the bird meant getting out of
the car
closing the car putting the key in you
know why and I'm here they can do this
this way as stuck in that can when they
hear something over and over again they
will mimic it to it do you know you know
they've actually used them to identify
murders cuz the bertigo no please don't
have children stop
the african great UCLA it speaks like
its speak it speaks better english than
we do african grey UCLA talking talking
like i mean yeah yeah this is [ __ ]
stupid this video makes me angry
you only Shangri the people hold on the
people that showed up for the einstein
talking bird white chocolate oh well you
know i don't have any friends never
wanted like you know like people can
train their dogs to the enth degree
where the dog you can bounce cookie i
religious and it turns around and for me
always feel like you're teaching your
dog how to do tricks which is kind of
undignified to the dog it's like let the
dog be a [ __ ] dog I know you have
total control over your dog but a
[ __ ] guy would shoot his dog in the
dog roll over and die I was like ah
dander is also standard we did find the
greatest [ __ ] bird video of all time
good work Jeff uh can Fabrizio found my
wallet yes I just got hiding fifteen you
keep losing [ __ ] bro I think you're
ready for the spin-off when you lose
your wallet fifty you're right
are you let's talk about this are you
nervous for the spinoff no I'm excited
though because they're playing is what
happened is it was dead right they did
pull it yeah and then now they're like
you know what because the young Sheldon
is kind of the same similar thing right
yeah it's believed yeah so and here's
gold here's Adam Goldberg saying we just
thought a spin-off was a slam dunk it
tested higher than the Culver pilot and
we were excited about taking to the most
popular
side characters and spitting them off
into their own show it on all the
elements all of us tells you to do well
and it's kind of like a family show so
it's kind of cool
so we'll see dude [ __ ] wait you know
I've never seen an episode of it it's
pretty funny it's actually a good show
right people love it man yeah I just
dare you got you dodge balls back when I
loved you a lot
but in return you have to save my
daughter from the tree freaks what I
thought you bought an all that stuff
about rainbows and ponies and trust hey
should we be standing here that kid has
a javelin
please look at his little arms we're
fine here's the thing John can't know I
came to you for help I swear to keep it
between us
besides I have literally no one else to
tell so what's the plan I got a whole
sack of plans right here let the healing
begin
well good job boys is that from the
spinoff from this peanut Oh sick but do
I hope you're all and we'll see what
happens now tell you look brother
it's how I luckily look yeah kind of a
kind of lose face I you know what why
wouldn't yet they should just call it
it's called gravity um I don't know why
I wouldn't go it's gonna test great yeah
the Goldberg family loves it yeah yeah
they have a huge fan base no I wonder
what kind of numbers they're looking for
I think they're just looking for ponds
and swamps media and all let's do this
man yeah it'd be really nice now but
when they announce it how long do you
think before you quit this show now is
it immediately if you want to give it
like a week er are you gonna be cured as
user or no try the kid oh you give us a
30-day notice or how do you want to do
this so III will not the way to replace
you free I'll send my assistant Brian
can no longer be on the show thank you
so much this is let me tell you
something I'm never quitting this show
if you don't think you don't know how
listen I realize it no I realize it
because you if you want to put your if
you want to put all your your coins in
TV go ahead please do if you want to do
that go ahead I've been in this business
forever this is the only sure thing yep
I cannot stand up before this podcast
yeah dude but let's change you say sir
you don't leave the mothership I've told
you this before you got big brown
breakdown it's amazing you got two other
shows it's absolutely different I got
this show this is your mother ship
mother [ __ ] this is the mother ship
funny kids are big big baby we don't
leave here this is our yellow submarine
if we leave here ever all is lost again
plus it's too fun and easy and it would
be terrible and if anything those ways
you're afraid to this this went on the
road together but you is gonna sting a
little bit once I was hoping this gets
picked up to have a replacement already
but it might come to move on in my
contract I've already worked out that I
have Mondays Wednesdays off as you know
I know
please give me another shot okay well
should we do the road together are you
afraid I'm down then you canceled the
finally kid in Vancouver why would you
tell me that what about the final from
our agent cuz we goes up in the air bro
uh Brian can do fine no I didn't know I
didn't know exactly the exact date I was
like I had no idea
they just got to me they just came into
contract so it's March I'm gonna be in
Saudi Arabia March 1 2 & 3
their fly me liebe Vancouver's before
Saudi Arabia yeah can I show you what
I'm fired up you will show you when I'm
done you know what we're doing now big
crabs just doing two stand-up shows now
yeah but you can do that that's good
that's more money for you yeah but you
bailed on me man
you son of a [ __ ] go Saudi Arabia you
know I hope having Saudi Arabia what I
hope they dressed you like a woman in a
scarf and [ __ ] the ass I apologize I
didn't mean that
I didn't mean that I apologize to
everyone Saturday thank you very much
sorry
thank you I don't yeah but you did
cancel I just did just now my agent goes
hey Bryan's are our agent goes it brides
out for the sack
Vancouver how you want to play it they
think you should just do another show
you by yourself went
I bet yourself okay okay I bet you saw
by okay ah okay because we have fun and
over together I think it was all my
favorites I really do want to do the
road together bring up Arab Emirates
private suites first class that would
have to be the deal in the contract
right 19-hole hey hold on
who do you think you are Brian go hey
bro this uh this takes a good you want
to go Saudi Arabia you can open for me
I'll give you this much money you should
seen the offer sir I just set out the
wheel birth how dare you I know how dare
you and I knew how much you were making
I through how to plan you know what you
never got a paltry so I'm not calling a
man my god you don't want to show your
mother greedy I was like and I realize
now I was like that's so obnoxious that
I even I went or I could just stay here
and do a show up the road it makes that
much I would not flight really thought
about like giving you some serious cash
board the problem how I wouldn't do it
to you yeah I mean I daddy's by the
house I gotta work I know just cuz we
have so much fun that dude we do a life
finally gonna be good for our show us
the jerk that's you know we're gonna do
our business of content and create
material and stuff like that you can't
just stay in that your regular schedule
you can't just go on set of the
Goldbergs do stand-up in LA and then do
a pot guys you're gonna run out of
content you know I can have anything
anything you seem to say you have to go
out you have to go like it was
life-changing for me when I went to
Australia like when I went so I really
want to bring I wish so I can anyway no
I in New York for I have to I'm a newbie
that's actually the reason I'm doing
Coover the Just for Laughs comment or
March first that once sold out and the
March 2nd apparently I have more work
and then on the 3rd I'm in of the Oscars
that's right that's right you have the
Oscars so unfortunately I wish that's
the thing I mean I was hoping I Saudi
Arabia can you pick any other time do
you hate - laughs everybody do you hate
big tan brown
I know make me laugh I look more
maliciously and bright I actually if you
didn't have to dress up like that I'd
talk to just I would dress up like it I
know I talked - jealous - my private
suite I talked to Justin that's the bed
you're not gonna jack off all 19 hours
in yeah it's my suite it's my private
suite
can you go just keep going with that
sure all headed man come with it he does
come with it he'll be there with me dude
yeah it's just designed by no - bigger
than that no mine is actually not a
choice like this right yeah that's
that's one example of it all right
anyway that's business class that that's
what I have I have the pride well we'll
see we'll see when you get there I will
see crazy you know I actually would have
thought I I actually would have had two
anyway I talked to Justin about it I
would have had to make it worth your
while because it'd be so good for this
show and the Zelan experience honestly I
sort of God be if it was even about what
kind is about the money cuz you know I
wouldn't be I would I was visiting the
other time I'd be down to do it I would
have figured it out if you didn't have
to do the thing I would have I told
Justin I go it's worth it to me to bring
him for a lot of money yeah I would have
given you an offer you couldn't
reproduce I'll tell you that much you
know next time you go lay down the land
you lay down the ground I'm gonna do
because welcome if you think so the
whole point how to add a guy a guy who
he's a son to some guy that he was big
in Dubai who's at a show and he's saying
they bring comics out all the time do
they know our podcast and and you know I
said we could kill it you'd be a toilet
groan - by probably you know what that
is yeah I know you guys know what toilet
girls are slime all right well hiragana
instagrammed see those girls really like
god that's strange why is she in the
middle of the ocean on a giant yacht and
looks like she's all by herself
how did she get there how did this work
out well I might have dated a girl
little story for you here date a girl
this years ago this is yours oh no no
that's sad this is years ago remember
this be yeah she every like few months
she would go to Dubai yep
and she like I have this app that I'm
starting out there it's a phone stuff
like a change and then she got an
Instagram or social media and she'd have
these pictures on the first class and
gold and champagne took like Jasmine
from Aladdin them what the [ __ ] and
there's no dudes in the pictures I'm
like wait the [ __ ] is she doing this app
must be seeking out expand yep and then
her friend was like oh she's a toilet
girl I mean she might she models toilets
no no no so these riches dudes in Dubai
fly hot girls out from LA or wherever in
the States Miami pick your fancy city
Russia Russia sure why not England
Australia everyone you name it they find
out then they pay them and simly but you
do some [ __ ] for india she might be you
might be yanked off to the toilet for a
night might sleep on the toilet
they might piss on you what about rub
their dicks in your whole checklist of
things you can yeah there's a whole
bunch my so I did it otherwise they
treat like [ __ ] but you get paid back I
dated a girl we were dating it went well
I met her at a gathering in Malibu and I
just she was just awesome and we started
talking and we started hanging out and
we started to make love we made love and
my my awesome place in Venice and she
was kind of my girl and I was like she's
I remember look at she was so hot and I
was like you're so hot but you're also
so cool and she had a business in Bali
that she had to go back for so he saw
his buddy right and it was like an
import-export business I was like she's
got our own business it's awesome and
she just disappeared and then she kind
of like disappeared and then she
disappeared came back and then she
disappeared again but I try to get
details about the business it didn't
work egg like [ __ ] on the weekend yeah
and I was like but are you in Bali we're
in Bali so long story short her friend
said Brian she's not in Bali she's if
she is in Bali she's with the Sultan of
Brunei because she's one of his girls
that's what she does there and I was
like yeah and she came back and she goes
I miss you you big jerk wait a min ago
will you stop calling me and it doesn't
work like that also dogs'll because you
don't mind I was
relationship if you don't mind I'm not
that jealous maybe you don't mind don't
you do not solve the through not what's
a Bolton of the world all over the place
your mind if you are can you film
infinity it's obvious yeah exactly so
anyway to do some current events let's
go to the bathroom
ah what do we got here we got chin got
some I got a few stuff Jessica Simpson
sued yeah I don't know much about this
but I guess she's she got sued for
posting a picture on her Instagram that
a paparazzi took of her it's a picture
of her so if they posted so if they take
the picture they own the right even
though it's you I suppose so
that's said that Daily Mail though such
a winner that girl remember I worked
with her and she got probably 50 notes
50 from the director and she took every
single one of them like I said like okay
do this do that on this line to that do
this huh she hit every [ __ ] beat she
was just professors Simpson the copy of
the foot photograph that Simpson
distributed on Instagram had been
altered without authorization or
approval to remove the CM i showing
plaintiff as the copyright owner of the
image that's insane they can take a
picture they own it of you yeah it is
really male and they're the ones that
supposed to post it but she posted it
what else she got the guy that played
Barney inside the dinosaur outfit he is
now a tantric sex therapist that's
creepy he said he was preparing for it
too by being in that costume Oh what
good this is the kind of know how big of
a deal Barney was yes I do cuz I know
the guy who oh my god came up with a lot
of the elements of Barney were a lot of
things I was training with in Tantra I
always said it was never an accident
that I was meant to do this character I
don't know what you mean sir sometimes
people talking I don't know what they're
saying well hey scroll back up and said
hold up joins massage practice has
around 30 clients or goddess all women
as the 54 year old describes in charging
around 3 and physiologists session which
helps them in his goddess release energy
and bounce their chakras
helps his goddess's release energy and
announces parties Barney's right of
course the unfit these all out of course
that's what's out in Barney's [ __ ] I
practice most people note of thanks to
famous practitioner singer sting Tantra
is a meditative approach to sexy till I
say some without being racist sure I
knew Barney was black you ever seen him
move in that suit no I know what I know
I didn't know man was the athletic is
that right yes he was look at that well
um good for you but does he do the voice
or someone else to have like see going
up whoa hey a Baldy blue Tara 315 that
way only in LA Tantra said hey but also
so what else did the voice so he just
was like in the sukkah my man my man
when that yeah how much money that how
much money is he make playing Barney
that wasn't me
Barney was also big you're my big
Barnabas there's tickle me out Tickle Me
Elmo and Barney it's funny I had a woman
last yesterday say to me I said I was
talking about this thing I said I try to
have sex with my wife twice a week to
keep things going said that yeah to this
random lady like who you know just like
I was saying in a marriage but you know
it's important to try to you know cuz
it's a verb you want to keep things
going she was just twice a week and I
thought like I watched you guys man I'm
about twice a day and she was she know
she's full she's havin a seafood 425
grand a year
well that's what he made miss Barham
nice to me when 2001 on that not mad at
that
well it's not that surprising I thought
he was even making let me see what he's
saying Barney was never how those make
me a bar do big your deal Barney was
being Barney was never an accident I was
supposed to do this character
[Music]
hi I'm David Joyner I play Barney from
1991 until 2001 this sounds like fun
after I got my degree in electronic
engineering technology I worked for
Texas Instruments for six years like a
club or handle SAT three four hours
Barney I was a live mannequin I would
move mechanically and people would
literally bring their children set them
on the mall floor and go shop when I was
a kid I wanted to be on television so
bad I would stand in front of the
television and basically lip-sync
there's a lot of psychic energy in my
family and there's a lot of clairvoyance
seen a lot he's on the spectrum do you
mean pedophile well the night before the
audition I don't think so I think he's
just down the stream Barney passes out
and I have to give Barney mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation so on the way to the
audition I'm sitting at a stoplight and
something says look up so I look up and
there's this billboard
it says breathe life into your vacation
Southwest Airlines and then it hits me I
had to breathe life into Barney in my
dream if I go into this audition breathe
life into this character I'm going on
vacation and that's exactly what I did
so of course they called me and asked if
I would be Barney and I said of course I
pretty much already knew that I was
gonna be Barney but it was great it was
great getting that phone call okay I
mean I guess it's a big break it's just
you know yeah when you think you're
going to Hollywood be an actor I don't
think you thought you're gonna be in a
fuzzy costume and no one see your prize
exactly
know what else you got Jim that Larry
NASCAR guy he got sentenced today so
it's gonna be 40 to 175 years in prison
but he's already happening to serve a
60-year term so he's gonna be in there
regardless oh he's knocked all these off
yeah that's like a lies he's a piece of
[ __ ] uh area those inmates gonna hold
him these far look at all the women
though that like these children these
girls I think over 100 right
on a 550 you piece of [ __ ] I mean I
don't know man
better to die I'd better just kill
yourself man I just don't feel like
that's justice I feel like you got to
put some pain on that man and that's not
why society works I just feel like you
got to do something
I'm have the homies run a train on him
every Friday yeah I don't know they just
have him rape him every Friday what are
their ID like what if they've loved his
open what if there's Darryl his brain is
wired in such way that he can't help
himself like he has a sickness still
monster though yeah which means he can't
be around children be Espeon jail but do
you put us someone like that if you find
that out do you put something like that
in jail or do you put him in a hospital
like say you find out that his brain we
find out that he's got a brain that has
something wrong with it right like
there's wide holes right it's wired
differently and he can't help himself I
know just the way I'm a homicidal maniac
can help himself
so then that that's my first question
what if I'm jumping ahead 40 years with
technology we find out that you put him
in a hospital you put him in jail and
second of all what if you can fix his
brain yeah a lot of experts say what
happens and how doctors say we're gonna
look back on our prison and judicial
system and laugh at it I suppose my god
Robert suppose it was so inhumane you
guys locked people up who is that for
these crimes who are crazy sick
yeah would you so you just leave them
running around it's just in question
because what do you do with killers no
so I'm saying I'm saying so if you could
fix him if you could fix his brain and
now he no longer has any interest in in
children what happens to the hundred and
forty victims and what happens to what
that guy used to because now you have a
new guy I'm just saying and when
technology is able to do this what is
that like what do we do fix his brain
and then he did his life is dedicated
his sentence is helping kids okay like
you know I'm saying like in a way they
just they just say no but no I'm saying
helping like he's helping victims from
other things or his whole and doesn't
get paid his whole life is dedicated now
to helping those victims obviously
there's no threat I don't know what you
do well it's a it's a I really have to
outsell them yeah cuz we don't have the
technology to fix his brain again the
help I would just kill it's a question
we're gonna have to answer I torch them
first yeah it's a question we're gonna
have to answer because like that's so so
the FBI
this really extensive this really
extensive sting on a guy who was trying
to blow people up in Florida and he
tried to join Isis but there was no
doubt that he was slow that he was
dim-witted and the the [ __ ] lawyer
was like this kid is so dim-witted that
he can't even think and then he tried to
back out they think but he was afraid
that Isis would find him and kill him
cuz he was gonna snitch on him so he got
this bomb and he was like fiddling with
it he was like you know they've made a
fake bomb and he's like this dude don't
throw it around like that then they
jumped on him and arrest him he's doing
a life sentence but the thing is it said
if you look at a lot of the people at
the FBI I've busted like the dirty bomb
or the shoe bomber the underwear bomber
they're dimwits they're their actual
idiots it'll help to solve his promise
that is who al Qaeda uses they used
dummies they use morons yeah so not
contributing to society they're trying
to hurt society yeah yeah you're rid of
them
yeah we have too many people on the
earth already I know it's so [ __ ] up
to say I don't I don't know I don't know
yeah it's a question what else yeah Jim
you alluded to this yesterday on big
brown breakdown that John Jones will be
back sooner than we think and Dana White
was on TSN and they asked him like you
know predictions for 2018 who would be
back he said Brock Lesnar McGregor and
John Jones um I think yeah I think he's
right brute Lesnar would surprise me I'd
love a Lesnar Francis fight I think if I
think with John Jones coming back swish
because that light heavyweight that
should force DC to go to heavy weight in
fights deep Bay I think it's gonna push
DC into that super fight with steep a
cuz DC's never gonna be John Jones just
not in the cards it will never happen
yeah so if you're DC you have one fight
left he's gonna retire sitting this year
so you have one fight left do you really
want to end it with another John Jones
long do not know go to heavyweight fight
steep eh yeah it's tough fight free but
win lose or draw it's still super fight
and you fight for every title and also
you retired the light heavyweight
champion of the world because you can
vacate the belt to go to heavyweight
potentially the heavyweight champion as
well ride off in the sunset as the Hall
favorite he's already a Hall of Famer
but don't wait around for the boogeyman
John Jones who's pissed off to come back
and kick you in the face again that's
right and it's hard for a guy like I
love
not to want to do that I know but you
know what it's just never gonna happen
it's just not yeah and then guess what
so then you you fight DC right her DC
fights t pay that's his last fight win
lose or draw he rides up sunset let's
say he wins you can vacate the belt then
your boy can can fight for the title cuz
that's what he wants yeah well guess
who's coming to heavyweight right behind
you
John Jones and guess what John Jones
does did that entire division beat them
all as he beat Cain Velasquez there's a
steep a I think he does he does I think
John is the greatest fighter that's ever
grace that locked you up I think if John
uh you know heavyweights night can be an
issue for him I've seen what John does
the heavy weight destroys him he's
better cardio better strike and I've
always thought that it like you told me
though that's that that Cain has a cage
around his spine so it's a different
thing but his injuries are gonna be
tough
yeah John John's okay Cain's not taking
John Donne Cain's not taking John think
so
really mm-hmm cain't Cain though with
his boxing his head in his chest pain
bang bang picking him up DC and Cain are
kind of the same fighter Gary is he yeah
he actually is no he's taller he's
taller not much taller but he's big
who's taller his shoulders I was just
with him just had leverage as his
shoulders are very narrow even Jay goes
it's crazy I know his shoulders are for
a heavyweight yeah so in his style and
DC's are exactly the same to 18 but
Kings give me a little stronger yeah
maybe a little quicker but he's had way
more miles way more injuries how's that
how's that game I don't think that I
actually think the fight is steep eight
John John said I think that would be I
actually would put my money I'd have to
buy my own a steep a it'd be tough not
to belet's D face so big in comparison
he's as big as John right he's a nice
big nope Steve Bay's thick as thicker
notice is paying steep a are almost
identical in size you and Steve I'm
actually maybe in the inch taller than
Steve okay we are identical a guy jump
John is way taller than me
wait I'll say way he's five six six come
on John's definitely taller me six five
six six but also Christ John walked up
when if he fight have you eight he'd be
shred city 230 shred sensitive cardial
for days
yeah but your 250 that's a big guy and
steep a steep ace how tall how big is
240 you know I 240 but also I've seen
what John Jones does this heavyweight
Smith yeah I've seen him go with Travis
round I've seen him go with our lives
have you have seen him go with me okay
all right and he's but he's just fine
like hard man he's so [ __ ] good it's
insane
yikes yeah I'm really gonna be excited
so he is gonna be back yep yeah he's
predicting that he'll be back this year
some more MMA ones Paul Daley is mad at
Bellator and Scott Coker did he start
funny when Jack Johnson started or how
long City no he fought Nick Diaz I mean
he's Hardy and really he is a hardy
warrior man that guy has been fighting
on a high level for ever that MVP fight
won't be happening under the belt or
banner so [ __ ] belt or throw nuts in
this game two more fights for a belt or
and I'm done so he's not taking his
fists gotta give the man respect so what
do you want to do why is he mad Coker
was talking up MVP during the presser so
I guess that was just insulting to daily
because he wasn't say anything about
daily even though daily beat Laurent Lee
no lorenz larkin yeah you didn't mention
anything about him he just kept talking
up MVP so he just wrote this on his
Facebook Wow he said he won't fight MVP
hey scroll up this way breaking news
coach says the plan is for a commentator
turn this year
alright that's nothing where's venom
page Minh he got hurt her nice little
page he got hurt then he's doing boxing
now he should be back okay what else
gotcha Michael Bisping
he said he was offered a fight in London
and he has until today tonight to accept
it or not and he's actually considering
retiring if he doesn't accept I think
that's a good thing
get that eye fixed yeah definitely I'll
tell you what if you want one more
that's fine do it against like a beat
doorbell for an older guy but also do it
at the end of the year or early 2018
don't fight yet I see out of the eye but
not as well as I
I'm still a young man so it's kind of
the reason I may hang the gloves up my
manager and friends and people close to
me say Mike what do you want to do for
that you've done it you're not really
great at all he's done it all is over
please please retire I don't want to see
a guy who's that great be hurt he's just
too awesome
I love Bisby what else you got Jenna
let's see him oh that flat earth guy is
just an update
he's gasps he's relaunching sometime
around February 3rd he's gonna prove it
finally yeah well finally one guy's
gonna prove her chancy nice and he's
also gonna run for California governor
all perfect didn't know you will not win
you know well you can't see the atom but
I'm pretty sure it's it exists since
when you split it it causes a large boom
that's correct yeah I can't see germs
either can see obviously tetanus or the
AIDS virus but let me see ah let me
inject you and tell me what happens yeah
do you guys use Waze yeah up for it saw
sting but you know so of group of
friends was using it near a lake and
they drove into the lake because the
Waze app told them that's the direction
they needed to go here's a few things
though so is dark and foggy that's not a
snowy
yeah that's I've been at Lake Champlain
this beautiful been there many times and
in ways Google actually had a
spokesperson say that we're not sure why
it did it and it actually led them to
and are they responsibility for it are
they going they said I'll be war hunts
and driving to Lake
yeah that's not getting it you gotta
know when in Denver in the tech center
there's like this like giant pond when
it snows it's tough to tell man and some
old lady was snowing it's all white out
she's like oh here's a parking lot I'll
park here and just DQ yeah died
why do you can't tell where the lake
start did it died because it's all
snow-covered and then the show goes so
it goes nice shops and shops lake like
pond giant pond yeah snow cover
oh here's the park in us park here no
one's here yeah weird way she's right
Eagles you can die by Eagles we just saw
you can die by Lake
imagine if there were real pterodactyls
because they could pick me up like you
going for a ride when a drop you and
spill your guts all over the silence is
awful like when somebody just gets
sucked into the ocean or this this
family was walking in Colorado on a hike
with their kid and mountain lions came
down and grabbed that kid and they never
saw the kid again just took off jumped
out grabbed it and ran like you know but
[ __ ] Oh what does that Jim do you guys
like Slayer to Owen Sleater do I Slayer
no final tour this year are you a fan
shin I was when I was younger
metal beard that's a lot of work to be
in you're 50 that's what they're saying
dressing up like that and your 50s is
exhausting I'm a fifty year old man that
would be big my god severely shower and
and my teeth
by the way how do you like this and then
bashing your head by the way went went
to the dentist and they go alright
you're not wearing your Invisalign Denis
had to come in and give me a concise
because you have to work okay listen
let's start from the V I think they need
our dental brace I starting from the
beginning so you have no chance I had to
do a mold I'm starting from waste of
time and tell me everyone we put it on
his Instagram you're never gonna wear
this I am now now I am you how did those
real [ __ ] no stop trying to get me into
metal braces
why are you doing this you try to get me
into metal braces as I want so he can't
take him off you're forced to wear of
course no one wants to wear but don't
force me to into metal braces blank
shamrock did it man I'd stop saying that
what else get chin uh goober driver he
robbed and raped four women and the way
he did it was okay he's illegal too so
you know so how's it [ __ ] up I had to
hand though but he would wait outside
different clubs and bars you know he
would have that uber thing on but you
know when you're drunk you don't you
think your goobers coming they just get
wait for those girls to come in and then
take them and then rape them and rob
them to Christ a gun boy he's arrested
again
I didn't hear gunpoint
leacy least he's an attractive man with
olives hair so just be safe out there
for your girl yeah but also let's go
ahead and look at that guy Ferg in the
car like I would just assume he's try
rape me some guys just look at y'all you
ranking off your rapey look at that
prosecutors present grisly theory on
submarine killing remember this yes a
billionaire what's the theory of kid
being bring it down you know bringing
avoid tools to brutalize him wall before
death yeah he's a [ __ ] torturer yes
horrible all right we got to read that
back bringing aboard tools to brutalize
Kim all Jesus saw screwdrivers what a
piece of [ __ ] this is they brought us
all starting screwdriver strap strips
pipes
yeah he's abused by hitting her stabbed
her and cut her and killed her after you
after which he dismembered the body
well [ __ ] see that guy we think yeah I'm
habilitated I would burn him alive but
not the guy who molested all the gymnast
I kill him too I'll [ __ ] kill them
all not on the same team I'm serious
team kill yeah I'm team kill on what
team kill Wow that guy needs to be
tortured in the submarine uh honey man
put him in prison with the homies rather
trainer he's a sadist he's a he's done
it before I'm sure it makes a mess has a
submarine for that reason that's true
can you tell me the only reason you ever
trust again green owns a center bring
you in under water look at think about
that poor woman and what you went to
hell exists on earth and you know
underwater in a submarine just nowhere
to go to the bottom of the English
nobody can hear you scream obviously
that's why he has a sub Maria he's a
millionaire or a billionaire first of
all have you ever trusted anyone who
owns their own submarine I don't I'm not
enough scary was a [ __ ] reporter
again don't jump on it somebody with one
man you just don't think somebody's
gonna be that insane but look at him I
have that spidey signal where it goes
hey you wanna join this billion or
submarine who else coming it's just him
and his tools nah hard pass hard pass
I'll go on that [ __ ] submarine to
Disneyland remember that thing yeah
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
and they play the Beatles song sure
soundtrack sure it's gone now it is you
have to jump on a billionaires submarine
what else you got Jen give us one more
uh how about this so this guy went to
Disneyland or Disney World
wearing this t-shirt that he made that
says I need a kidney zero positive blood
call the number someone asked to take a
picture of him that person ended up
putting on their Facebook it got shared
over 90 thousand times and then someone
actually called in saying I you know I'm
a no it ended up being a match and it
saved his life saved his life saves is
that so freaking fan man that's you
scroll up a chin have you seen this
people doing the tide challenge eating
the tide thing so they look like candy
and then people are like getting rushed
to the emergency rooms it's that bad bad
yeah it's time I purchased ya Tide
detergent yeah oh no I said person no
what the doctor explained and you know
Rob Gronkowski had to do a video going
kids do not eat these it's not a joke
it's not fun teens are eating the
laundry detergent uh-huh type iPod
challenge a viral social media stunt in
which you put a coated caps of laundry
detergent which resembles a gummy candy
they do look delicious like you had in
your mouth and record your action as the
pod dissolves and the first 15 days John
18 there were 39 reported cases of
potential tie pod ingestion month
thirteen nineteen year olds a poison
control center it's at arrow ideas as
the doctor thank you doctor that's not
very good let's not do that crazy right
yeah all right man what else you got be
tonight watch the Goldbergs tomorrow I'm
in Columbus funnybone Friday 2 shows
Saturday 2 shows Columbus funnybone DC
improv get your tickets now they're
going actually pretty fast which I'm
very happy about that would be February
1 2 & 3 and then we got Brea improv
February 8 9 and 10 so come out and see
me Brendan with a [ __ ] e you gonna be
next week I'm in Denver yeah Denver get
your tickets now Denver I'm there all
next week and then Friday Saturday I'm
in st. Louis get Joe ticket funny bone
st. Louis go see Brennan and that no
helium I'm sorry the helium insane
and then on March
I'm sorry than the end of the month I'm
at La Jolla Comedy Store which is base
san diego-la jolla Comedy Store Thursday
Friday Saturday that is February 23rd to
the 25th and then March first
Coover Just for Laughs comedy tour and
we'll figure out that one that bran
canceled on me we'll figure it out
yeah and then end of March I'm in
Florida Tampa Bay Palm Beach get your
tickets now T back a.com this is the
final ten we're out